cuál es el punto bienvenida y profesora
de dialogar si no hay confianza entre
las partes cuéntenos su opinión
justamente yo creo que este proceso en
particular empieza
por reconocer que hay que construir
confianza es decir la confianza es algo
que se logra precisamente en la
admitiendo que el adversario tiene
algo que que ceder y a la vez cediendo
pues en aquello que pueda contribuir a
acuerdos que en definitiva mejoren la
condición de los venezolanos yo creo que
esta negociación a diferencia de otras
tiene muy claro un norte que para mí es
muy importante y es precisamente la
construcción de un conjunto de reglas
para poder empezar a resolver el
conflicto político venezolano que no se
resuelve con unas elecciones de uno u
otro tipo únicamente sino que implica la
construcción de unas nuevas reglas de
juego político
el memorándum de entendimiento va en esa
dirección y ojalá que el proceso pueda
alimentarse en esa dirección también con
el aporte de la comunidad internacional
y de la sociedad civil venezolana que
está muy
a diferencia de otros procesos en esta
ocasión y claro que si éste de manera
extra audiencia profesora porque igual
yo podría considerar que no se puede
confiar en figuras como el ex
vicepresidente jorge rodríguez eso
demuestra fragmentación dentro de la
oposición venezolana
bueno indudablemente una de las razones
por las cuales la negociación puede
prosperar es precisamente porque la
circunstancia de cada
de cada parte política tanto del
gobierno de maduro como de la oposición
venezolana no son
digamos están vamos a decirlo así
bloqueadas ninguno de los dos puede
esperar mejorar su posición relativa sin
negociación hemos llegado a un punto en
que la crisis afecta pues a las dos
partes de tal manera que es
absolutamente necesario empezar un
proceso de acuerdos básicos como digo
que nada estará garantizado hasta que
realmente se vea si se pueden llevar en
la práctica pero la desconfianza no
puede ser un obstáculo digamos la
desconfianza puede ser algo que ocurra
pero no puede ser un obstáculo
para para un momento que el país
necesita muy muy importantemente para
reconstruirse no estamos a venezuela hay
que volverla a construir a recuperar sus
instituciones sus reglas de juego su la
capacidad del estado de cumplir con sus
funciones mínimas así como la oposición
necesita un espacio para reconstruirse
como opción política y hacerle una
oferta de futuro a los venezolanos
entonces
y yo realmente creo que el problema no
son las personas que están negociando
allí sino los temas y crear que esos
temas son los adecuados claro no es que
justamente queríamos preguntarle por qué
wide o sostuvo y al igual que usted lo
acaba de mensura que las elecciones no
son la solución a la crisis que
atraviesa el país a que sea esta
afirmación y entonces como usted también
lo menciona cuáles son los temas que se
debían estar discutiendo en mexico
primero con las elecciones no son por sí
solas la solución a los problemas del
país porque los problemas del país no
son solamente electorales o no son
solamente políticos en el sentido de
cambiar un gobierno por otro
yo creo que no se estaba refiriendo más
bien al hecho de que no hay confianza en
las elecciones pero eso forma parte del
proceso que estamos viviendo se ha hecho
una serie de negociaciones con el
consejo nacional electoral y las
elecciones de noviembre de este año son
elecciones que se van a van a tener
lugar en condiciones totalmente
distintas a las anteriores que se había
deteriorado muchísimo el sistema
electoral pero al margen de eso las
elecciones tienen que ser vista como un
parte de un proceso de reconstrucción un
proceso de reconstrucción institucional
del cual las elecciones forman es fácil
pero también el tribunal supremo- el
sistema de ayuda humanitaria sanitaria
que la educación la salud etc